in the latest episode of I'm unable to
notice irony or understand double
standards Donald Trump jr. went on Fox
News again and tried to smear Joe and
hunter Biden again and this time he said
I wish I was able to make millions of
dollars off of my father's presidency
are you being serious done you did it
congratulations whether you wanted to do
it or not you've made millions thanks to
your father's presidency this is a
segment that is indistinguishable from
satire here is what Donald Trump jr.
said to Sean Hannity last night and of
course this is projection this is
cognitive dissonance this is so many
things other than what Don junior and
Sean Hannity want it to be which is
somehow Excalibur Tory for Donald Trump
imagine look at all the media protects
Joe Biden no Biden's on tape and a quid
pro quo either you fire them in six
hours or you're not getting the billion
dollars that fire them you get the
billion dollars quid pro quo then you
got do you know anything about Ukraine
know anything about energy no oil no gas
nope
millions of dollars oh that was the guy
that Joe demanded to be fired
imagine if that was your name was hunter
Biden except oh I wish my name was
hunter Biden I could go abroad make
millions off of my father's presidency
I'd be a really rich guy it would be
incredible but because my name is Trump
if I took one point five dollars from
China not one point five billion like
hunter but one point five dollars their
heads would explode Don I hate to break
it to you you do go abroad all the time
and make millions because your dad is
Donald Trump here's a headline from a
very good piece and the Los Angeles
Times from a couple of weeks ago Trump's
children take in millions overseas as
president slams Biden's son this is a
very good detailed well researched piece
on the many ways in which the Trump
children not Tiffany or Baron of course
just that the top three the older three
Eric Don junior and Ivanka a really good
piece about how they are making
ton of money making deals overseas this
is a classic propaganda technique by the
way projection uh used in a number of
different ways here it's accused the
other side of that which you are guilty
of and that is what they are doing here
and I have to ask you this question a
second time I asked it to you last week
because we had a similar appearance by
Don Jr on Sean Hannity are you this
stupid Don jr.
or do you just think that the Fox News
audience is stupid enough not to see
straight through your BS arguments here
unfortunately he may be this stupid but
it actually seems many of the the
supporters are as well because if you
look around online in the typical
Trumpets enclaves or even if you talk to
trumpets in real life they've fallen for
talking points like Oh
Trump's losing millions by being
president he's not doing this for
himself he's at a loss for being
President of the United States
what another talking point they've
fallen for the Trump kids are no longer
doing deals they are just advising Trump
no that one is demonstrably untrue it's
actually sickening how far we've been
desensitized think for a moment if a
Clinton or an Obama had brought on half
their family as advisors while they were
simultaneously monetizing their
positions to the tune of hundreds of
millions of dollars a year do you think
that there would be the same flippant
lack of concern from right-wing media
and from trumpets about what was going
on of course not do you think that if
Chelsea Clinton had sat in for Hillary's
Secretary of State at the g20 that
Republicans would be doing anything
other than scandalizing it 24/7 on media
no and instead you've got trumpets not
only looking the other way about Ivanka
and Eric and Don jr. while playing as
they play a huge role in trumps
administration some of them are actually
going out and almost defending them like
martyrs who are willing to forego
millions of dollars just to help the
United States oh what a martyr Ivanka is
and Don
Jr and Eric Trump which is of course
completely bogus and it's inaccurate
given that they aren't actually forgoing
anything now I have one other idea on
this is it possible that what we see and
interpret as ignorance or cognitive
dissonance from trumpets when we see at
rumpus defend this stuff is it possible
that it's not actually ignorance that
it's not actually cognitive dissonance
is it possible that trumpets see
themselves in Trump and his kids and
their nepotistic corruption and they
want to be like him and they know if
they were in their positions they would
do the exact same thing to self enrich
through the presidency but they can't
say that out loud because it would look
bad so they just defend it in these
other ways by saying Oh Trump's losing
money by being president or just an
eyeing the facts on the ground is it
possible that that's why we are seeing
what appears to be ignorant and
cognitive dissonance I don't know I'm
asking the question let me know what you
think in a youtube comment if you're
watching on YouTube otherwise I want to
hear from you on Twitter at D Pakman and
make sure while you're there follow at
david pakman show on Twitter as well to
get all of the latest show content
delivered to you concisely and in a
timely manner in your Twitter feed quick
break and we will be right back with
much much more after this today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is
komm slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma
n